[Music]
is going to tell you important make sure
that all working remotes are present at
the time of programming after you enter
programming remote mode it will delete
the other remotes that are not available
so I do have men only working remote
with me this would also be available on
the app and on the website here I would
normally have product images visited
brand new vehicles we are uploading
those but I'm going to continue to
programming options like I said I am
doing a proximity remote so I am going
to select fob and proximity remote
programming
I have 90 minutes to complete this
programming there are also two options
for this car but you will see that there
is only one option for proximity remotes
proximity remote is option number two
the first option is just for a standard
remotes that will not start your vehicle
how many remotes you want to program
please do not count your original
remotes and would only like to count one
do not disconnect the OBD or USB cable
and some programming is completed we
give the ignition off open and close the
driver's side door continue
I would like to program keyless make
sure my ignition is off so my ignition
is off continue system is ready to
program keyless I'm going to please
continue again I have to input the pin
code that I have received from my dealer
my pin code for this vehicle is five
three two seven zero four I'm going to
hit submit I did receive that pin code
from my dealer after clicking continue
within five seconds use the top end of
the keyless remote and press and hold
the start button
so after hidden continue I have five
seconds programming successful would you
like to program another remote that was
my original remote and like we said all
remotes must be present so I now have my
new one I do want the programming other
one so I'm going to hit yes
after clicking continue again I have
five seconds to hold the top of this
remote against my push-button continue
and it says programming successful I
would only like to program to remote
slammed in a complete programming I am
going to back out until I have turned
off the blue light at the bottom of my
smart box and as you can see that blue
light is now off I'm good to unplug my
smart box from the vehicle
I am putting the our existing remotes
away from the front seats I have my new
remote and I have started the car once I
start to turn the car off I lock and
unlock buttons do work on my first
remote as well as on the second
[Music]